well that was quick valence getting a
release date Borderlands three is going
to the Wild West no I'm not gonna sing
the song and more free games are coming
to Xbox game bass I'm Lucy and these are
the biggest gaming news stories for
today Thursday May 21st
I forgot what day was I think we all saw
this coming but valent is rolling
straight out of closed beta and into a
full release on June 2nd and yes I'm
British I say beta so the bad news is if
you've been playing for the last two
months right is going to reset your
account so you'll be starting from zero
so sorry if you've been playing ranked
but kinda works out in my favor cuz I'm
terrible so so the good news though
they're gonna be patching in new content
shortly after the game launches that we
new modes characters maps and more the
beta ends a week from today that's
Thursday the 28th and I'm very much
looking forward to seeing you all back
in overwatch for five whole days before
you go back to Balor and it's fine I've
made my peace with it
borderline 3 is getting more DLC and
this time we're going back to the future
part 3 because it's a Westend pretty
heavy huh the borderlands show revealed
bounty of blood a fistful of redemption
that'll pit you against a bloodthirsty
gang called the devil riders the DLCs
director called it a harsh story of
revenge and redemption probably of the
red and dead kind there's a bunch of new
characters like Juno and Rose who'll be
acting as your guide and some talk of
NPCs and locations changing based on the
decisions you make in side missions most
importantly there'll be a new trusty
steed to ride and god help me it better
handle better than the vehicles did in
the main game you know what I'm talking
about
anyway DLC drops June 25th game pass
continues to be the best deal in games
dropping more free titles on Xbox one
and PC that's right I know we just got
Red Dead Redemption and Final Fantasy 9
but Alan Wake City skylines pleb eQuest
the Crusades and some dungeon crawler
game based on an indie property called
minecraft I don't think it's gonna catch
on
Alan Wake and City skylines are
available now with the other two rolling
out over the next
days if you love to control as much as I
did then definitely pick up Alan Wake
because the new control DLC is
apparently going to explore the
relationship between control and
everyone's favorite author who isn't
Stephen King Alan also have you ever
noticed how many layers Alan Wake wears
enough forget from June first we're
going to be doing our play for all event
see what I did there it's gonna be a mix
of basically what we'd be doing at e3 so
all the latest games developer
interviews but we're also going to be
doing a charity stream as well with
people that you know and love like Greg
Miller Troy Baker Alana Pierce and more
check out the website the full schedule
of games and guests will be up shortly
tomorrow we have a new episode of good
news gaming which I host we have stories
about the most wholesome streamer in the
world and Tony Hawk being a bro
hopefully see you there
[Music]
you